kelly is with us in florida hi Kelly
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show hey Dave
thanks for taking my call
sure what's up me and my wife are in a
serious dilemma I'm a firefighter and
she's a online schoolteacher we have a
combined income of about $80,000 our
total debt including our house our
vehicle and our credit cards is about
three hundred and ten thousand dollars
how much of that's house 243 thousands
what's owed on the house okay my my
vehicle is paid off my wife's vehicle is
a 2015 traverse that we owe 26:4 on and
I think it's worth about 21,000 so we're
upside down by five thousand mm-hmm but
our biggest problem is our credit cards
we kind of got taken on the house so we
use the credit cards to fix the house
and combine or about 50 thousand dollars
in credit card debt mm-hmm in terms of
my question my question is are we at the
point of filing bankruptcy to get rid of
the credit cards not even close right
okay not even close no you guys are at
the point you need to be on a budget and
you need to chop up the credit cards but
listen I put bankruptcy in the same
category I put divorce in it's what you
do after you've tried everything else
and there is no other alternative and
then you still waited two weeks okay
because it's not in any of your fun trip
I did it
it's 30 years ago I did it it's not fun
I don't recommend it for anybody I mean
there's good people go through it I'm
not gonna be mad at you if that's what
you end up doing we'll still be friends
but you know I'd sell the car I'd work
two jobs you're a fireman you be on 24
off 48 or something i'ma work at an
airport so we work like 60 hours a week
just solid straight through okay gents
and this this income includes all that
overtime yes sir
okay good all right anything you can do
for extra money either one of you and
I'd sell the Traverse even if you
stopped paying the credit cards and paid
them nothing what are they gonna do
eventually three years from now they'll
get around to suing you right
and your credit will be run by the time
three years gets around I think you
could have make an ad could have taken
care of 50 sure okay and you could have
done it pennies on the dollar and you
weren't bankrupt you just had some bad
credit card debt which is on a scale of
one to 10 a bankruptcies of 10 bad
credit card debts a five or a six okay
and so you don't want to do that but the
Traverse is killing you it's got a big
high payment and I would dump it first
and foremost I'd look for extra work I
get on a tight budget and the two of you
join hands and say the stress is killing
us I hate this minute in our life in our
marriage we don't want to live like this
anymore
I've had it let's change our ways
because you've done a series of
decisions that brought you to this point
and this is your opportunity to do a 180
agreed yes sir I mean a bad car purchase
a bad house purchase and a bunch of
stupid credit card debt on the bad house
purchase did I miss something that's
that's everything yeah I've done it too
man that's why I can see it it's real
clear and I mean I was done when you
were so I got you beat man so here I how
old are you guys 25 no no I'm 38 and
she's 36 okay all right I should have
measured caught that there's yeah you
you're not can't do that by 25 all right
so all right so what we're going to do
is we want you guys to go through our
nine week class and one year membership
in Financial Peace University as our
gift and we'll walk with you as you guys
go through this because you have a very
hard 12 months ahead of you my friend
but you do if you file bankruptcy - yes
sir so you got a hard 12 months coming
it's just a matter of what medicine you
want to take what do you want to do you
know gastric bypass or whether you just
want to do on diet and go on workout you
know what I'm saying sure sure and so
gastric bypass is the bankruptcy I'm
gonna do that as absolute last resort
after I've tried everything else and so
let's put you on a diet and put you in a
workout regime I think I can help you
turn this I then I can see the numbers
you're just beat up and tired of
fighting it and you feel a lot of shame
from being stupid but we all do that
brother so no more shame this is time to
move on hold on
Madison's gonna pick up we're gonna sign
you up for Financial Peace University my
gift to you some day later you find a
young firefighter who's
Okin scared and you pay for it for him
but I'm giving you yours this is the
Dave Ramsey show
[Music]